[Music]
hi everyone thanks for coming to this
presentation I'm Elena I work in
booking.com and there every day I have
to build a model that will run in
production by that I mean that they will
really run on our website and determine
what to show to the user so in this
presentation I would like to share some
of my learnings when I was working on
that kind of projects and I hope that
then you wouldn't have to face this do
the same mistakes that I made in my work
so as the first question I would like to
ask how many of you actually made a
model machine a machine learning model
that was running in production like that
I mean in a website or in some kind of
software hmm that's quite a lot of
people that's great and how many people
would like to build that kind of model
to run it in production so I hope then
this presentation would be useful for
quite a lot of people so in working that
core we have enormous amount of data
about users something that can be a
problem for one company where you have
only a few thousand users is not a
problem for us we have enormous amount
of information a Norma's amount of data
we have computational power to run
machine learning models on that amount
of data and we have a system that allows
us to productionize these models within
a few minutes so it sounds like we have
solved all the problems what else can
actually go wrong when you want to build
your model in production actually the
answer is almost everything can go wrong
and let's start with the first problem
the problem is where you want to apply
your machine learning model to improve
the user experience if you look at
booking.com our website is quite
different from the websites such as
Amazon a Facebook or users go there
weekly or daily or five times per day
depending on how addicted you are to
Facebook our users usually make booking
maybe once twice per year and that can
be very different types of
walking's so some people go once per for
ski vacations and together some summer
trip or some users only go for a trip
where they need some business trip that
makes it very hard to predict what will
be the next one
and how can based on the previous data
we can help the user to make a new
booking another challenge is that most
of the users are not logged in so we
actually even if the user made a booking
you actually not know about that bit
before you he logs in so as a result we
have a continuous cold start problem
then you might think okay we don't know
anything about users how can we even
make any machine learning models without
this information and it turned out there
is that there are enormous amount of
areas where you can do machine learning
modeling to help the user even if you
don't know a lot about the user one of
the examples is content summarization if
you come to our website there is an
enormous amount of information that can
be very overwhelming for you that we can
summarize to the user so that you would
not have to go through all this and just
have a small piece of it as an example
it you can look at the review data that
we have so if you want to book a very
good hotel you usually go to their view
page you have a thousand of reviews and
most obviously you don't want to spend
three hours of reading all of them so we
can run a topic detection model that
actually identifies what kind of topics
users were talking about in their
reviews and we can summarize them in
such a small table that you can see on
the hotel page 111 users were saying
that stuff was great
86 users were saying that location was
wonderful
so you see machine learning even we
don't know information about the user
but we can help another area of machine
learning that can be very useful for
other people so when users browse
through the website and maybe you are
one of these users you usually see ok I
have so many different options different
price different facilities different
locations how would they find the best
hotel when I get best facilities for the
money that I pay and we have a model
that does it for you so a model that
determines whether the very firm
is actually good or not so that kind of
models we call content evaluation so
instead of you evaluating all this
content with the help of machine
learning we do it for you and then we
just add a small icon that says great
value for money another option is to
segment users so we have all types of
users that have very different behavior
although when user joins the website it
doesn't necessarily tell us okay I am
that kind of user please provide me this
information so one of the examples can
be users that are flexible in date so we
can have users who already bought the
tickets to a particular destination and
they need to come on this Saturday and
users who haven't bought them yet so
they can come two weeks later two weeks
earlier and then they are way more
flexible and then we can provide them
different suggestions on the best dates
for best prices but if the user is not
flexible this kind of information will
be very disturbing for the users so it
we better avoid it and although users
might not tell us specifically whether
he is flexible on dates or not we have
our training data where we know which
users what kind of users actually change
that date eventually in their search and
we can train this classifier for that
kind of user segmentation so now you
have seen that there are a lot of models
that you can use to improve user
experience even if you don't have a lot
of history of user interactions but when
the user joins our website and as soon
as he or she starts to click on specific
items we kind of get it
gathering for me this kind of
information that can be relevant for us
and with these interactions our users
become so-called warmer so we can
actually start doing personalization
based on your specific behavior okay now
we saw that there are a lot of models
that we can build but how to build this
models is it actually that easy and
there are no problems at all yeah of
course not you can guess it from the
title of the talk so the first problem
is the data although we can have
millions of different data sets it might
not be always the data set that you want
to have let me give you a simple
let's imagine you want to predict a very
simple thing whether you as a user would
like to have a breakfast or you want
don't want to have a breakfast okay this
is just a linear binary classifier and
if you look at the data what would you
assume you can divide our users into
three categories those who need is
breakfast those who don't need and maybe
a small party that doesn't care however
actually we don't know what is the
intent of the user because there is no
place on the website where we asked
about that the only thing that we have
is users who made a booking and from
that users we see who actually bought
something with a breakfast and those who
didn't buy a breakfast as a result this
is what we observe and this is what we
actually want to know there is some
small overlap but this is very tricky to
say that exactly everyone who is here
have the same behavior of those users
that we observe and giving this limited
amount of information of course you can
make different assumptions you can you
might say that okay users who made a
booking and users who didn't make them
looking are exactly the same and then
you may not want to based on those users
who booked and extrapolate your results
to all users well there is a problem
because indeed you make this assumption
you basically estimate the conditional
probability of your action in our case
it's the users who make
booked a breakfast giving that users
will book and that can be very different
user it can be user that will book
anyway so actually our model would not
help them because they maybe it's a
business trip they would book whatever
you show to them but we will actually
want to help the users who are confused
with the information so there are a lot
of ways how you can deal with that kind
of problems where you have some portion
of the data where you have labels and
another part of the data that actually
doesn't have labels so it is you can
look at different papers about positive
and labeled learning and it will also
depend on what kind of type of data you
think you have and what
kind of labels you have okay sometimes
you can work with that kind of data
where you only assume that you know the
labels based on some kind of condition
you can also look at the problem from
the other side and say okay I want to
identify users intent from some other
interaction that kind of interaction can
be for example filters that users click
so if you clicked the filter that you
want to have a breakfast this is exactly
your intent and then we don't need to
limit ourselves to only those users who
made a booking that can be a solution
that's great
now we answer to our question but not
exactly because if you click the filters
that you want to have a spa this is your
picture in your head but what you end up
booking might be something like this and
you also perfectly fine with that
so the fact that you filter it on
something doesn't actually explain us
how important is this which feature to
you is it crucial for you to have a
breakfast but or is it something you can
have it oh if you don't have it you're
fine then maybe you want to look at what
happens after that whether user actually
and click this filter how did user
behave later on this is a tricky part as
well another challenge with the data so
user is not static when user come to a
website you can start with explore phase
you say ok I want to come to my data
event in Amsterdam I want to make a
reservation for two guests for one night
in Amsterdam you start searching oh my
god a night and Amsterdam 200 years okay
and by the way I have a child with me
and you actually want to stay for a
Sunday as well so it's two nights and I
have a child you refine your search you
understand that it's super expensive
there is no nothing good for you you
will say ok I will stay in Harlem
probably you define your search you made
a booking what do you have at the end
you have a lot of information about the
same users where you have different
values for the same feature so if your
feature is a number of guests here you
have two guests here you have three
guests user change the destination user
change name number of
and the longer the search of the user
the more information you will have if
you just train your model on this raw
data you might have a very strong impact
of the users who made a very long search
that have I don't know 50 different
searches and ended up booking and those
users who had like only two searches and
booked after that so that's very
important how you compress this
information so we would have fair
estimation of what was the impact of
particular feature and that will that is
not obvious at all how did I summarize
these features should I take only the
one that were at the beginning so when
the user entered the website or should
they take the mean median mode I think
the main answer for that will be it
depends on what you want to get at the
end if you want to run your model once
when the user made his first entrance to
the website and you don't want to change
anything after that
that makes sense to take on these these
features if you want to change the value
of them of your prediction on every step
that user makes and then change on the
website accordingly then you actually
want to be correct most of the time then
you might look at the mode of your
features or maybe you want to just make
a final prediction correctly and then
you only when you are at that stage you
want to change add a change to the
website and show me something different
so let's say that we have perfect data
everything works now the second
challenge is a modeling even to the same
even if you have the simplest thing to
do for example you want to rank the
hotels on our website based on user
preference you want to show to the user
the most probable hoto that user would
like or book it is not so simple to do
let's imagine you want to just make a
binary classifier which will say whether
user will booked this hotel or not you
can imagine that when you try to train
your model on the observational data
there is at least one very tricky part
the probability that user will click or
book the hotel that we showed in the
first position is not exactly the same
at the hotel on a position number
135 because not all the users will
scroll down and that creates a problem
that we have a very strong position bias
which is not so trivial to estimate from
your training data rather there is a lot
of discussion in the literature how can
you estimate this physician bias so that
you can actually train your the model
not the fact that okay what was on the
first position this is what user will
book and one of the simplest way how to
deal with it is to make data random
randomization so you show all the hotels
in random order so relevant hotels and
in relevant hotels can occur on the
first position and from that you can
estimate this position bias and you can
put it in your model and then you model
the real intent of the user not the
intent of the user plus the position
bias of course there can be a challenge
with this approach how do you think what
can go wrong if you show random hotels
on the first position yeah and that kind
of hotel can actually be something super
irrelevant to the user you can if maybe
your user who is looking for a luxury
hotel and you show him a hostel users
can get pissed off and just turn and
never come back to our website so there
is a very nice paper by I think Google
from this year you can check this link
where they discussing how to make this
randomization with lowest cost or even
if you don't have a randomization how to
try to approximate this position bias
another problem although we might think
we know what we want to do we can mix
the definition of user intent and the
outcome let me explain you on the
example so let's return to our task
where we want to predict whether user
want to book a property with a breakfast
or not so when our website you can see
both options for some hotel source some
hotel can propose you can pay you don't
have a breakfast but if you want to
compact and euros extra for that and
here the breakfast
includ and again we want to predict
those users who will book something with
a breakfast so what I did is a binary
classifier what can be easier I have all
my data I trained it and then I decided
to look what kind of coefficients do I
have what turnout is that the main
coefficient that determines my outcome
was the city where user goes to which
actually doesn't make that much sense
well maybe some you can find a
hypothesis that can explain it but I
thought that sounds a bit tricky then I
looked at my data what I saw is that in
some cities for example in st.
Petersburg we have 2000 hotels and 75%
of them don't have any breakfast because
it's mainly people who rent their
apartments so they just don't provide it
and in cities for example like Palma de
Majorca 66% of the properties include
the breakfast by default there is no
option to not have a breakfast so just
saying that for all the users in st.
Petersburg say they wouldn't have a
breakfast and for all users in Palma de
Majorca say that the will I already have
a pretty good classifier that predicts
everything correctly in 70% of cases but
do I actually predict what user wanted
to book or do I predict what user had to
book because for the first 1500
properties that I wish out to the user
in st. Petersburg there was no breakfast
and no one ever looked at at our page
number 300 to find it I think we are not
actually predicting their intent that
well in that case so in that case when
you have that kind of problems where
they intent and the outcome don't match
it's very important to double-check all
your coefficients analyze your model and
also test it in an experiment to see
whether what you predict actually match
to what user do in reality when we
introduce our intervention and here it
comes to to the very important point of
all this modeling process is to do
experimentation so no matter how good
your model was when you're testing it
offline on your training and test data
you had the best performance in the
world
it actually might not be that good in
reality that's why in booking.com we
have about maybe more so then thousand
experiments running simultaneously on
our website where we divide our users to
base and variant and we measure whether
there is a significant difference in the
effect and by doing that we can
definitely say whether there is some
impact on the real user or our model was
performing manual only on test data and
reality is very different so as you can
see there are a lot of challenges when
you model when you do the modeling and
you want to apply it in production and
there are no golden rules that will
solve all your challenges that's why
it's very important to try to learn in
smaller steps test everything in
experimentation find these hidden biases
adjust them and run another experiment
to set to test whether you know
accounting for everything so that was
the presentation thank you very much and
I wanted to mention that we are looking
for data scientists and specifically in
my team we are looking for data
scientists with background in NLP so if
you have some relevant knowledge please
approach me and I will be happy to
explain anymore thank you very much
[Applause]
well it depends on whether there is a
some kind of user cookie and what kind
of device is user used so that will
definitely depend not in all cases and I
did that can be tricky again and went
users change the platform so you're
working on your computer and then you
came and started booking something from
your mobile it's also something that you
can added identify
so the question is yeah giving that we
run so many experiments simultaneously
can it actually hurt us and identifying
whether there is an effect or not indeed
so there can be a problem with that
that's why we try to monitor these
things so we try to understand whether
there it can be some potential
interactions between them and if there
is and we don't run this experiment
Samanta simultaneously but our website
is huge and we are not running on
experiments only on the website but on
many different things so we try to
isolate thing that we want to test and
if there is something similar that you
want to test then people wait and the
team will wait till the previous
experiments will be over so the question
is you know although we don't know a lot
of information about user bookings there
are another features that you can use
are new modeling like the time spend on
a website the time when user logs in and
can we use it in our models indeed so
for example you can think about user
location or a place where user wants to
go well how many days user wants to go
so it all describes user preferences
although we don't need to know who is
this use room and and anything about the
the previous bookings so these features
by itself already very strong features
that give us a lot of information on
what can be the best property for the
user of best useful information and we
do that indeed any more questions
[Music]
the question is how do we take into
account events about which we don't know
so for example if there was a concert in
a particular area so the question is
whether we actually it's important for
us to know about this event so not
always there but we do take into account
some historical trends in the data so
for example there might not be a
specific there might be some contours
that are randomly allocated but there
can be some concerts that are always on
the 9th of June yeah I don't know in
Amsterdam so then by taking historical
data into account next year we can
predict the true below availability in
this area ok any more questions all
right in that case I would like to have
[Applause]